for David and I we've always thought
that if we could just cross over and do
filme courage com full time we probably
gain more opportunities because you're
devoting more time absolutely so what
did you see in terms of because when I
quit jobs or whatever had some time off
I noticed that there'll be a flurry of
activity and all sorts of stuff starts
happening and then once I start
depending on a paycheck yes stuff dies
down yeah so can you I'm sure you can
relate to that absolutely yeah I well
that's it kind of goes and having a
couple of things having a couple of
things going even right now if I could I
would kind of pare down some of what I
do and focus on the things I want to do
more but I know I can't I can't do that
i teach improv comedy and I love love
love doing it however it's a lot of
energy to put out it's a lot of time to
put out and if I had to um if I had to
cut something out it would be that but I
can't sit there and be like you don't
let me just cut it out and you know jump
in the net will appear yeah I still I
still realize it like I'm not that I'm
not that great you know where I can just
be like oh the world is just love me and
hand me money so you know I think you
put those you know you put those long
hours into it yet the more you put into
it the more you're gonna get out the
more it's gonna become valuable and you
know you pee you know it becomes
something that generates an income or
from that you find a way to generate
income like for me like I take my
youtube channel I'm like how can i make
money on my youtube channel with not not
just from videos whether it's brand
integration writing things for other
people so i always take something I'm
like how can i make money five different
ways from this one thing and not just
how can I just make money like just from
it without kind of branching it out so i
would i would just say keep pouring
heart and soul into it keep it you know
you got to keep it up there because you
know you let go that site i should say
or you like over youtube channel for a
month two months I mean you you're
you're you're almost back to zero you
don't you don't just come right back
into it so it's a lot of a lot of upkeep
and just find creative ways to you know
keep those people coming in whether it's
aggregating content that people
love and you know I have a facebook fan
page and sometimes I'll just put stuff
that's like nothing to do with me but I
think this is funny but what it does is
gives people to share my facebook page I
get more facebook followers and they
want to put a video I get more views so
I just yeah I just fine i just find
different ways and for me it's a lot of
trial and error and like looking to
other people to see what are they doing
it's so successful and see what i can
borrow what do you say to those people
that say well i just want to get to your
level and then have my people do it for
me well they yeah they all they all say
that you know um you know there's people
that are whatever there's people that
are need to lose 100 pounds and they
want well I want to be um you know 65
body fat and then everything else um
doesn't United mean it doesn't like it
just doesn't work like that for some
people they do they even though the
people that put up one video and it goes
viral they people might not care about
anything else we put on after that to it
the same way you have to you know
nothing is really that easy you think
it's easy because it's just like oh
you're just putting up you don't see
what goes on behind the scenes the most
successful people they have long you
know you're working a 40-hour week job
some of these other people are putting
like 100 hours a week into their YouTube
stuff and they're you know dollar for
dollar you're probably making more money
sometimes but they're living their dream
and they know that there's you know the
payoff will calm but it doesn't seem
like work people just don't see what's
the kind of like glazed over look you
have in kind of keeping your keeping
your internet personality up there it's
a lot right i mean it's still a job
you're still at your computer and your
kind of clocking in for yourself yeah
how many filmmakers were you too you
know celebrity you do you know that can
actually quit their jobs not not that
many um you know it also depends on like
you know what their what their lifestyle
is you know if you if you're willing to
let you know I'm willing to live very
you know kind of like I just love what I
do I don't care about things so I'm kind
of lucky in that sense but there you
know there's are some people that
creatively find ways to make you know
make money but yeah a lot of you know
that's like actors in Los Angeles at how
many that are making a living one
percent to whatever the percentage is
it's
pretty low so it's this it's the same
with its entrance hall it's all
entertainment it's all kind of delivered
entertainment you know whether it's TV
or YouTube
you